hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome to episode 6 of network chat
programming so today we're gonna talk
about grid bag layouts
last time we took a look at making this
client window which looks like well
doesn't only able to take anything yes
we haven't added anything to it it's
just a pretty big window so if I just um
actually run the application you could
say that what we can do is once a little
login thing pops up we can type in a
name you know Cherno put up in an IP
address and the port like a 192 for
example hit login and we get this church
our client window again and then from
here what we want to do today is
basically add components to this window
we want to add a a big like text area
over here so that we can um see the
history of all the messages that have
been sent and received we want to add a
little um text field here so we can type
in our message and then you know when we
hit enter or press the send button which
will put right over here will actually
send the message to everyone who's
connected so that's what we want to do
when I'm basically a big text area a
text field down the bottom and a little
button in the bottom right corner that's
our goal for today also as you can see
this is resizable which is good we might
actually set a minimum size will do that
layer but it is resizable and that's one
of the reasons we'll be using the grab
bag layout which i want to talk about
now so over here in client dot java
in our design if you make sure you're in
the in the design view you'll see a
bunch of bunch of little things that we
can add it out pull up you know palette
view play palette so in our palette view
under layouts we have this grid back
layout okay and there are so many
layouts that you guys can play around
with but what I found is I only use two
layouts ever honestly the absolute
layout which is also not known as the
null layout I guess because you set a
layout to null to use it the absolute
layout means that whatever coordinates
you specify for your components they
will be there no matter what they're not
gonna move anyway they're gonna stay at
that exact absolute position and the
other one use is grid back layout and
basically so basically let me just cover
this
absolutely out I use for any window that
does not it doesn't need to be resizable
so for fixed sized windows I always use
absolute layout for resizable windows
latest grid black layout and the reason
I use dad is because what you can do is
you can set weights to all the different
components and what will happen is you
can actually change how they you know
resize themselves how they move around
the frame when you actually make it
bigger or smaller when you resize the
frame the window that's the reason I use
grid back layout otherwise we could have
just used absolutely app but the thing
is if you want to be resizable you know
that's not gonna work at all because the
the components aren't going to change
size or move they're going to be fixed
but we want them to move along with our
window so in other words we want our
little button in the bottom right corner
we always wanted to be in the bottom
round in the bottom right corner no
matter you know no matter what size the
window is now a grip a cloud is one of
the best and most complex layouts and
what I'm going to be using all the
features certainly but we are going to
cover the features that we need so let's
click on grid bag layout and then over
here just click on the in just click on
your window make sure it's not on the
title bar make sure it's in the actual
panel in the window alright and then
what will happen is it'll add it and
let's just check out the source code of
what that looks like so you can see that
what we actually popped up Oh awesome
and put it right into create window
that's great I thought it will put it
here but it didn't that's awesome
say it was a good window builder is
let's just check this out so what is
done is this this section occurred here
it's made a new grid Bakkal out and it's
made all these like arrays and
everything and that might be a bit um
that might be freaking complicated for
you guys but we'll take a look at what
it is okay
so basically it's created a new code
back layout okay and then it's set delao
to that grid back layout
now what you can do what we can see here
is instead of adding it adding just a
nuances of flower because usually what
you'll do is you could just basically
essentially just settle out yeah - let's
just say a new board allow okay that's a
pretty popular one right what is done
here is has actually just created an
instance it's created a variable out of
that
and then it just set that instance to
multiple things because we want to set
its properties that's what it's done
here and then once it's set as
properties it actually sets the layout
of the frame to be that great background
okay so that's what it's done right over
here it's gonna grab some water okay so
well then what are these properties a
descent that is set ah column widths are
essentially the width of every column
I'll talk about how grid back layout
works in a minute but um basically the
way that it works or probably should
cover that now I think if we just grab a
component like a button and put it here
yeah I'm okay that's perfect you can say
that if we grab a component like a
button and actually hold it over the
window you'll see a bunch of grid like
basically a bunch of cells appear in
inner in a grid here and what they what
these cells are are all the positions
where we can actually put the button you
can see that we can't actually put it
into precisely in between of course we
can modify these grid cells their woods
and everything but what you can see here
is we actually we actually can't place
it in between by default you know what
what window builder does is actually
gives us this this kind of view it
automatically gives us these things they
don't exist yet okay because you're the
source we can say that we've actually
don't have any columns or anything we're
gonna got one column on one high one
column and one row and they've they're
both got 0 so that they're basically
non-existent yet they have width and
height of 0 so this is like a preview
thing but as soon as we place something
so let's have to go up place in that
where is it J text area moving for that
where are you here we go so let's grab a
J text area and put it up here okay
let's just click that and you can see
it's put it it's distributed here now it
takes out the whole window right now and
that's alright but we'll call it uh
we'll call it history yeah history text
area history so it's called history
let's just get rid of the history text
over here okay so go back to source we
can see we've actually created two now
but more importantly we've we've we've
got all these new constraints that we
can set and this is just like the grid
back layout is so complex and with it
you can really achieve pretty much
anything it's really really nice
but um what it's done here is it's kind
of expanded you can see there's actually
added one more one more index into this
array one more integer into this array
and here as well but it's also created
this this text this text area that we
just created and it's created the grid
grid back constraints for it
okay so fill grid X and grid Y okay and
we can also set its weighting later but
we'll do that in a minute so let's let's
just play around with this let's make
the first column width be you know let's
just say we want about ten pixels of
padding so we'll make the first one ten
and then we'll make the text area how
big is our window let's try this out so
I window width is eight hundred and
eighty as you can see over here so we'll
make the second column let's just say
well I guess we'll just make it eight
hundred and sixty and then we'll make
the third one ten now this clearly is
just for now because when we add our
buttons we'll have to add a few more
grids but you'll see what I mean
so and we'll do the same for this as
well so ten and then let's just say it's
550 let's just say 480 or something and
and then I guess what blue tan and then
we'll have to work out the difference of
that some of the lives us 50 pixels of
extra space there okay so we've got this
now
that's all I've done okay let's let's
flip into design and see what we get
okay
so now without text area sort of
disappeared completely and the reason is
it's kind of in between it's in this
little first one so let's change the
grid X to 1 and the grid Y to one and
say I've hit design and we can see now
is our little J text area is actually in
that grid so if we just run this quickly
oops make sure you put a port number
that's valid you can see ad
our Tech's are sort of appeared here and
we've kind of got control over what it
looks like right now it's still too high
at the top so we need to fix that but um
essentially that's how it works and if
we resize it we see it kind of stays
with this thing and it's not perfect at
all but you can see if we type something
like that
and we resize it it doesn't doesn't go
past that it's actually really nice so
with that we've got the basis of what a
grab-bag layout looks like um let's
carry this let's go back into the source
okay
so what what you can do is set these
grid X&Y and they actually correspond to
the index of the array so you can say
that as I've said this to one it's using
a hundred and sixty so let's put it
right there it's put it into this one
and grid why of course is put it into
this one okay if we set this to true for
example just so we can see what that
looks like and we launch this what you
get is it's actually going down here
okay and the reason it's gone down here
is because we're using the 50 that we
said over here the 50 pixels of padding
that we've said over here it's not
padding but the 50 pixels that we've sat
down here okay
not using the 481 now the reason that is
not perfect is because when frames are
resizable when J frames are resizable
this isn't the this isn't zero zero and
that's not the width by height
coordinate it actually it's actually a
bit different so we kind of have to
fine-tune this to see what exactly the
um deviation is but if we live it's
about 15 15 this probably needs to be
about 20 and let's put this back to one
it does on one if we check this out then
what we should get is something that
looks generally all right let's move
that down even more though so let's
maybe make this about 50 and check this
out okay
kyoool so that's looking pretty good we
can change a lot of this around let's
just let's just take this out then
because otherwise it's not actually
going to make any difference but
20 preview this one one time and that
should be pretty good okay so you can
see that now this thing is moved down
that's too far but the idea is here that
you needed to play around these numbers
figure out exactly where you want them
and and figure out also the weighting of
everything so I'm probably not gonna be
able to talk about waiting because this
is get this is gonna be a pretty long
tutorial Green Bag ladders really um
complicated but really powerful so let's
at least get this text area to align
properly I think maybe 20 if we put 20
pixels of padding here for the raw
Heights we'll probably put about 40 and
make this maybe this needs to be about
32 biasa make this 30 30 30 and then um
what's our hide again 559 I up to 550
will make this 40 then ya know why yes
it does sorry how the level study as
well again I'll check this out okay
that's probably pretty good there might
be too much space here yeah so let's
change that a bit let's set the width of
this to be maybe 865 and the mr5 wait
this doesn't even hang on this mass is
all wrong alright let's make this if we
want to make this we'll have to make
this like this because remember the it
has to add up to 880 the biggest mistake
that people make let me just make this
clear as well with this grid Bakkal out
when you save column widths and row
Heights what you're actually doing is
you're setting the width and height of
every column okay now if if if this some
of this is not equal to the width you're
gonna get problems okay because you
can't possibly have grid bag columns
that are actually you know in term in
turn they're they're wider than the
actual window because then it kind of
overflows you can't have that and that's
where most people get errors so if you
do this properly if you make sure that
that that the some of this equals 880
and the some of this
equals 515 then you're gonna be
absolutely fine so that's the prototype
and the reason they are adding 550 of
course are because that's what we set
the size to be now now we've done that
let's show this out one more time log in
okay almost so this will take a bit just
take a while so as as we decrease this -
let's just say 17 you we need to
increase this by the amount that we've
decreased so the date so that the sum is
still equal to the width so eight let's
try all that okay I think I think that's
pretty good
we might even just make this make this a
bit wider so if we make this too wider
and then subtract this to seven and
there's sixteen all right yeah that's
right is that right I'll say okay that's
pretty good and then the height we might
increase to maybe about 35 and thus
decrease this to maybe 75 so we've
increased this by five so we need to
decrease one of those by five all we can
share of course how much really crazy by
okay that's pretty good and we've
probably said packages in itself okay so
that's how that works
we'll talk about waiting next time and
then probably after that we'll start
adding more components but essentially
that is the basis of our message history
thing so next time we'll actually talk
about waiting because as you can see as
we drag this this doesn't increase in
size there's a text area and it and
instead we've got this this white is
just just this white space over here so
we need to fix that but anyway hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of Navajo
chattering pretty complicated episode if
you need help or if you think Ivan cover
everything perfectly
I might draw you guys a diagram or
something I'll just do an in-depth
episode the cover square bag layer
specifically but if if you need help
just leave a comment and I'll probably
the answers to some of your questions in
the next video but until then it's
actually my last episode in Germany
because I'm leaving tomorrow I'm
actually flying out back to Australia
finally uh-huh it's been like eight
weeks so yeah so hopefully there'll be
more frequent uploads when I get home
but um yeah if you enjoyed this video
please hit the like button I will see
you guys next time goodbye
you